or insulin is a is a hormone that we  make from  certain cells in our pancreas and when  someone has type  1 diabetes the disease is they aren't  making insulin anymore  and because insulin is essential for  survival they begin  a course throughout the rest of their  lives of giving themselves regular  insulin injections  and one of its main actions is that it  will lower blood glucose levels when we  eat something starchy or sugary  blood glucose levels will start to climb  if glucose stays too high for too long  that's actually  dangerous even lethal and so insulin is  a savior in that sense  it will come to certain cells on the  body especially muscle cells  knock on the door of the muscle cells  open doors  for glucose to come rushing in out of  the blood into the muscle giving the  muscle some energy and other  tissues other cell types as well